Howard Reynolds kind enough to call into
the program here from the MLB Network
and MLB tonight which airs live before
and after every single postseason game
how are you Harold my friend how you
doing well I got to tell you what that
that game last night sure seems like
something that was so significant that
it's difficult to come back from that
said it is game a game I mean that's all
Aaron Boone could say after the game
last night what do you think well I mean
there's a couple ways to look at it
clearly a blowout it was ridiculous with
the final score 16 to 1 but there was an
opportunity there you know the Yankees I
thought they didn't play it with much
urgency you know to me I look at it like
okay if worst-case scenario if you lose
to yesterday you have to play today in
New York and then you got to go faced
Chris Sale on normal rest for Game five
and to me the last night's game was
critical for the Yankees you got
Severino going you got a healthy bullpen
once he got into trouble early and I'm
saying the third inning was first a
second no outs and and they continued to
keep pushing through that inning IIIi
think you got to go ahead and take him
out of the game and you're only down a
run or two at that time and after that
the floodgates opened up and I just
think they didn't handle it well where
you you're sitting there saying here's
what's in front of us we've got to win
this game tonight I didn't think they'd
play with that type of urgency well yeah
and I guess the Yankees do have somebody
in CC Sabathia on the mound tonight who
is well versed in and stopping problems
for the Yankees I mean he might be the
perfect pitcher for this evening what do
you think about tonight's matchup
Harold yeah I love I think he's gonna
keep minute the the difference with CC
now than CC ten years ago he's gonna
give you five you know and then what are
you gonna do so you're facing the team
that's red-hot right now I love the way
the Red Sox played the hit and run
stealing bases and Evers was running
last night Mookie Betts scores from
first on a double they did a lot of
things without hitting the ball of the
ballpark and that's what presents them
was a very difficult Club to be so I
think CC is going to
there but we'll see what happens with
that bullpen and yeah now you got I
think the thing takeaway last night as
well was evolved going you know into the
eighth inning the Red Sox just hardly
nobody out of the pen and so today
bloated ready to wrap this thing up and
I just don't see the Yankees uh coming
through the series they may win today
but I don't see them come back and win
it two more in a row I just don't see it
well it's tough to win two in Fenway
Park and now if that's what the Yankees
are gonna have to do to get through to
get it against the Houston Astros team
who I want to talk about with you in a
moment but Harold look I know it's easy
to to say this sort of stuff because
it's not easy to do the job I'm about to
bring up but whatever but when a pitcher
when a pitcher doesn't perform well like
say David Price he's he's benched if a
hitter has a particularly bad night
after a bad night before or a bad you
know or a career in which you're
wondering what somebody can do or not
they are benched how in the world is
angel Hernandez allowed behind home
plate tonight to call balls and strikes
in a crucial potential closeout game
after what we have seen from him
certainly last night you know you look
at the replays kind of made it stand out
sometimes empires disappear replaying
keep moving but he had a rough night
last night but it's the way it's set up
you know they're great guys throughout
the year and as bad as the public might
think angel Hernandez is then go back
and great guys and and over the course
of his 162 game schedule
he stood up enough to be in the playoffs
so you put you're trying to put me in a
hot spot here sorry Howard
no I understand how to percentage you're
saying you know when when you don't
perform it I think that's the
frustrating thing for players and
managers everybody's held to a standard
and I think baseball starting to do that
with umpires I've seen a few guys not
brought back to the postseason this year
and angels still sliding by so we'll see
if he he contain
to be able to skate that but the iron's
hot right now and and the eyes are upon
him we'll see I tonight do you think
there's some in the front offices in
Major League Baseball a little nervous
about his you know the problem is once
you get a bull's-eye and it doesn't
matter if you're a quarterback if you're
a pitcher or hitter or higher once you
get that bull's eye he's gonna call one
ball that's questionable tonight and
Yankee stadium's gonna go berserk and
those are the things you try to avoid I
remember Ernie Harwell you saw I say
hello
I did it on powered like a dead driver
in traffic and never noticed that
noticing that angels in a red car and
everybody else is driving a black car
right now you know that's the difference
how Reynolds here on the Rich Eisen show
the Astros are still the best team
correct in all of baseball starting
rotation the depth of the players and I
think there's a hunger there and an
attitude and I don't know if you caught
what I'm forgetting his name right now
third-base and he's killed Bregman
Bregman what Bregman had to say
yesterday about the fact they were
playing after just games did you catch
that part oh yeah that the Astros are
are the defending World Series champ and
they're not in primetime the Yankees and
the Red Sox are in prime time oh yeah
they're the warm-up act they're like you
know I'll be honest with you Harold
they're like the Houston Texans in the
playoffs they're always the first game
on a Saturday afternoon of a lob card
weekend whenever they're playing at the
same time and being around that team
last year that's the wrong team to give
that little chip on the shoulder their
plan for more now that's right okay you
guys gonna treat this yeah okay you'll
see it we're made of and I think that's
what we're seeing to me they are the
team to beat like I said no doubt about
it National American League there they
are the team to beat in baseball right
now they sure are I mean I can't I can't
see the holes in that lineup they're so
damn good I mean just the minute that
Bregman is you think that he's the best
player on the team George Springer
remind you that he hits
runs like Reggie Jackson in 1977 you
know it's unbelievable in October it's
scary in Korea and Altuve are just
starting to get hot too but when you
have a guy like Marwin Gonzalez you can
throw all over the place and he can
produce for you and then the combination
of the guys they put it first and and
they just got a really deep line up I
like how they play the game AJ Hinch is
really coming to his own it seems like
he's making right moves right time and
the whole key is to have the freedom to
make moves but also know you're close
and that's I'm difficult right now
so what is their weakness is there one
pitch that maybe throughout the lineup
well they have trouble handling middle
relief I mean what would it possibly be
their their Achilles Achilles heel might
be if their starters don't go key you
know the first time Verlander went five
innings and they there's a bridge too
soon to the closer and that can be a
little bit sketchy on any club even if
you should get different guys to put
them down there so that's it Chili's
Hill you got to get to those starters
early and really be able to knock them
out but you know the thing about the
last thing I'll make with them is in the
postseason right now the team that
scores first I think 11 of the 13 games
or something like that the winner has
been the team to scores first the two
losses where the Astros came back and
beat the Indians twice you know so
there's not a lot of things that they
can't do they can play from behind they
can play from being ahead they're
definitely they're very talented couple
more minutes left here with MLB
network's Harold Reynolds Emmy Award
winner and part of the Emmy Award
winning MLB tonight which airs before
and after every single postseason game
handicap the NLCS for me it's Dodgers
read Brewers what do you got for me on
that front well I think the Brewers are
sneaky man you know the Dodgers loved it
to do this matchup thing and I remember
sitting on a set with Joe Girardi and
Joe even in one of our meetings saying
the Dodgers are the perfect team to
bullpen against because they love the
matchups if you can flip that lineup
around a few times you might get them so
when I look at the Brewers this patina
setup really to get to their bullpen
they're gonna ride this pin as far as
they can ride it and they got lefties
righties they got great matchups
there so I think you're going to see
them really try to make the Dodgers flip
their lineup in and out of the game so
that will be how I think they hang with
them their offense is playing real well
right now this would be an interesting
series I don't think the Dodgers walked
through like a lot of people think the
Brewers are going to give them a run for
the money well what does it explain that
what Joe Girardi said I mean how do how
do you beat the Dodgers by making them
turn their lineup well let's take for
example joc pederson usually plays
center right but he's starting against
the right-hander yep so let's say they
like yesterday in Atlanta they started a
left-hander
so joc Pederson is on the bench you know
now sudden you got Taylor playing
different places you're moving their
lineup around you know you're taking
ground all what are you going to do with
him so now you get an inning two into
the game or like Atlanta did yesterday
to get to the fourth inning and now they
flip and they bring a right-hander in
well here comes joc pederson you just
lost a player off the bench
Matt Kemp's coming out of the game now
you know so those are different ways to
force them as you get down to the end of
the game make a decision what your
lineups going to be and you can break up
that continuity you may have a chance to
beat and there's only there's only two
or three guys Turner's gonna play
everyday Machado is gonna play everyday
and not even Muncey's playing everyday
with him 35 home home so you really got
two guys that are driving to the park
going I don't need to check the lineup
card I'm in there everybody else is
trying to figure it out
and they're getting the text message in
the morning from the manager saying okay
you're in but if you can mix that lineup
up you're gonna see the strengths or the
weaknesses of the Dodgers how they have
to run out everybody and that brings me
to my last question because I'm still
searching for somebody who wants to back
my play on this one Harold okay I think
the Dodgers are going to see they've
already have what Machado is they've
ever ebuddy knows how great he is in
baseball I think that the fans are gonna
fall so had him over heels in love with
this guy and what he might do to the
Brewers and/or world series is gonna put
the front office in a spot where they
can't let him go they cannot let him
walk and they're just gonna have to
figure out a way
with Turner and Seeger and whoever else
to keep him on this roster what do you
think I feel yeah I think he's already
starting to do that but I just don't
know where the money's gonna end up with
Manny and there's gonna be so many I
think if the Dodgers or suitors I should
say I think if the Dodgers were gonna
lock him up I won't say they missed
their window but now you've allowed
other competitors to come in I thought
when they traded for him they'd sit
there and try to sit something hammer
out a deal now once this is an end
you're gonna have 15 other clubs coming
they're saying Manny because we're gonna
here's what we're gonna bring to the
table and now the Dodgers are gonna have
to bargain with somebody else out there
when they had the bargaining chip all to
themselves well I mean but it's not like
they're broke I mean they certainly have
the money right they've got the money
and they've got the Sun and they've got
the beach and they've got the Dodgers
name of across the chest I don't know
he's just so damn good and and if he
starts winning in October games in the
same way that he's won a couple now I
just don't see how they let him walk no
matter how much the Phillies or who else
there's gonna and I believe this about
LA you know I think the Dodgers have a
chance to win a World Series this year
and and you could be a hundred percent
right but I also look at it like that's
a new market in LA now in the sports
market sooths LeBron fine with the
Lakers they became relevant in that
dollar that people are spending you know
you only have so many consumer dollars
going around all sudden the Rams are
playing great before it was just SC
football and the Dodgers and now all
said you got some competitors and so
you're gonna need a gate attraction it
matter I bring people to the stadium you
wanna watch them play catching a ground
ball the way he throws the way he hits
it's one thing to have a pitcher you see
every five days totally different with
an everyday player and to me that's the
cell if I'm the Dodger front-office I
want to lock him up because he's an
everyday gate attraction love it but how
dare you how dare you overlook the Chris
Paul Blake Griffin DeAndre Jordan
clipper era Herald okay
a call of Kershaw starting anyone you
like that you like Kershaw game one yeah
I mean I kind of would like say no game
to the shoulder but he'll be Kershaw
it's gonna be great
it'll be fun to watch and they'll be
competitive look he's on the road or
he'll be fine
sure I'll be great all right 8:00 sharp
if the World Series is out here I'd love
to have you in studio again you got
absolutely you got I could wind up good
wine up in Milwaukee - you never know
Harold you take care of all chats I'll
be watching you how the moon Alliance
bills and Vikings I was on fire this
past Sunday take care you bet same you
got hats HR album the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience